antes de empezar vamos a ver un extracto
de uno de los discursos más recientes de
vladimir putin lo vamos a poner con
subtítulos para que podáis notar todos
los matices de la entonación no buena
versión de esta línea maestra ma
ying-jeou gestor pública un criptana
frustrando una socialización esas
pasiones y que actúan de esta crítica
mayo will be so y la pregunta que os
estáis haciendo muchos en este momento
espero de que traidores habla vladimir
putin pues no os preocupéis porque en
este vídeo os lo vamos a contar
[Música]
[Aplausos]
en el momento en el que hacemos este
vídeo casi 4 millones de refugiados
ucranianos ya han abandonado su país
pero todo eso ya lo sabéis sobre todo si
vivís en europa probablemente incluso
alguno de vosotros esté acogiendo a
refugiadas en su propia casa sin embargo
en el vídeo de hoy vamos a hablar de lo
otro éxodo si hablamos del éxodo de los
rusos y miles de rusos se han marchado
temerosos de que vuelva a caer un telón
a cero habéis oído bien en realidad los
que estén suscritos a nuestro patrón ya
lo sabéis muy bien porque lo hemos
contado en uno de nuestros últimos
boletines semanales por cierto que si os
queréis suscribir a nuestro patrián
tenéis todos los links en la descripción
no sólo podréis recibir nuestro boletín
de análisis político semanal sino que
también podréis conseguir nuestro
merchandising exclusivo camisetas como
esta por ejemplo que no están a la venta
en ningún otro lugar pero volvamos a
nuestra historia de hoy porque los
refugiados ucranianos han recibido una
cálida bienvenida en europa y esto no
sólo es por solidaridad con ucrania
también es por interés económico
[Música]
si no nos hemos vuelto locos los
refugios de su cráneo no son casi un
milagro para muchos países europeos por
ejemplo polonia está cogiendo a más de
un millón de ucranianos una ciudad como
varsovia ha visto como su población se
ha incrementado en un 17% en sólo unas
semanas y todo eso son buenas noticias
porque casi todos esos refugiados son
gente joven que tarde o temprano
encontrará un trabajo pagará impuestos y
pagará pensiones habéis oído bien con la
calculadora en la mano el problema de
los refugiados no está en el país de
destino sino en el de origen sin embargo
si la guerra termina con unas
condiciones favorables para ucrania es
lógico pensar que muchos de estos
ucranianos volverán a reconstruir su
propio país sin embargo qué pasará con
los rusos pues seamos honestos no no van
a volver
la diferencia entre los refugiados
ucranianos y los inmigrantes rusos es
que estos segundos están huyendo de un
sistema político cada vez más
autoritario y esto es un problema para
rusia casi tan grande como las sanciones
en otras palabras rusia está perdiendo a
sus mejores trabajadores informáticos a
abogados consultores vamos casi toda la
materia gris de este país está marchando
a toda velocidad en jerga económica esto
tiene un nombre descapitalización y
donde hay un problema para rusia hay una
oportunidad para el resto del mundo
porque todo ese talento tiene que llegar
a alguna parte y creedme si hay algo que
nunca sobra en un país es talento y aquí
es donde viene el auténtico problema que
vamos a denunciar en el vídeo de hoy
europa no los está aceptando habéis oído
bien y alguno dirá normal esto será
parte de las sanciones económicas contra
rusia verdad
[Música]
[Aplausos]
pues nada de eso porque en realidad
aceptar inmigrantes rusos ahora mismo
sería un castigo añadido hacia rusia
como para poder hacer un ciberataque si
ya no tienen hackers cómo van a poder
recuperar su economía si sus mejores
talentos ya se han marchado entonces lo
que quiero decir y por eso la pregunta
que hoy nos hacemos es por qué europa no
está aceptando los inmigrantes rusos con
los brazos abiertos porque debe hacerlo
lo antes posible y lo que es más
importante como debe hacerlo hoy vamos a
responder a todas estas preguntas pero
antes antes muchos nos habéis preguntado
que cómo se puede colaborar con el
ejército de ucrania y la resistencia
pues bien el banco nacional de ucrania
ha abierto una cuenta para aceptar
donaciones de todo el mundo ese dinero
irá a financiar la resistencia contra la
invasión rusa si consideráis que esto es
una causa justa y queréis ayudar tenéis
todos los enlaces en la descripción vaya
por delante que esto no es un anuncio
nadie nos paga por decir esto y lo
hacemos simple y llanamente porque
creemos que es nuestra responsabilidad y
si por si alguno se lo está preguntando
yo sí he hecho mi donación porque creo
que es algo importante pero de nuevo
esto es algo muy personal y no voy a
intentar convencer a nadie y ahora sí
vamos a un poco de historia
[Música]
nueva vieja rusia
el 31 de enero del año 1990 mcdonald's
abrió su primer restaurante en la plaza
púshkinskaya de moscú más de 5000
personas hicieron cola ese día para
probar por primera vez en su vida un
bigmac y ganó se muchos no os lo podéis
creer pero durante muchos años
mcdonald's en rusia era algo así como el
sitio cool donde te llevarías a una
primera cita un símbolo de esa nueva
rusia que por fin se abría occidente
pues bien desde hace dos semanas
mcdonald's se ha marchado de rusia así
que todos esos restaurantes que antes
tenían la gran m de mcdonald's han
cambiado el nombre por esto
exacto a partir de ahora los rusos que
quieran un happy meal tendrán que irse
aún aunque hoy van ya y alguno dirá pues
mira mejor para ellos porque seguro que
ahora los rusos comerán sano
esperar que es que hay gente que dice
estas cosas de forma irónica por si
alguno lo piensa la respuesta es no el
hecho de que mcdonald se vaya de rusia
no significa que los rusos se vayan a
volver más sanos todo lo contrario
[Música]
prácticamente todas las multinacionales
se han ido de rusia eso significa que
los rusos ya no pueden comprar muebles
de ikea ni iphones ni camisetas de zara
y tampoco podrían pagarlos para que os
hagáis una idea ha habido días donde
solo había un único cajero automático en
todo san petersburgo mientras tanto
putin no deja de censurar páginas web de
miles de personas en la cárcel por
participar en protestas contra la guerra
y esto es sólo el principio porque no
hace falta ser un premio nobel de
economía para predecir que lo peor está
por llegar y todo esto explica lo
siguiente el talento tecnológico se
marcha de rusia mientras las sanciones
occidentales empiezan a morder y alguno
dirá pero y dónde está el problema pues
mejor para los rusos que se queden más
sitios para aparcar verdad evidentemente
no creedme esto es toda una tragedia
económica pesado así el recurso más
importante de un país no es ni su gas ni
su petróleo es su gente ojo esto no es
un mensaje políticamente correcto es la
realidad el capital humano es
fundamental para cualquier economía y
como os podéis imaginar los que se van
de rusia no son precisamente los más
tontos
[Música]
en realidad rusia lleva sufriendo una
fuga de cerebros continua desde el año
2014 hablamos de abogados contables y
sobre todo informáticos es verdad que
rusia nunca ha sido precisamente el
paraíso de la tecnología pero en un país
de más de 144 millones de habitantes hay
cientos de miles de personas con talento
por cierto muchos de ellos son
especialistas en ciberseguridad recordad
todos los vídeos que hemos hecho en
visual político hablando de los hackers
rusos pues bien toda esa gente puede
encontrar trabajo en cualquier parte del
mundo y creedme muy bien pagado sin
embargo el punto de inflexión ha llegado
con la invasión de ucrania
[Música]
pensadlo bien es ahora cuando las
mayores multinacionales se han marchado
del país por ejemplo es en marzo del año
2022 cuando las 'big four' se han
marchado de rusia las 'big four' por si
no lo sabéis son las cuatro mayores
auditoras del mundo ya sabéis y white
deloitte pricewaterhouse cooper y kpmg
estas cuatro empresas daban empleo a más
de 15.000 trabajadores cualificados en
rusia por supuesto el hecho de que estas
marcas se vayan no significa que hayan
despedido a todos sus trabajadores
pensad que todas estas grandes
consultoras trabajan o trabajaban como
una franquicia al más puro estilo de
mcdonald's es decir que al igual que han
hecho con mcdonald's lo que antes era
del hoy de rusia ahora pasará a llamarse
de otra forma
ahora bien han perdido buena parte de
sus clientes y eso significa que la
mayoría de sus empleados están ahora en
baja temporal hasta que le reubiquen en
nuevos proyectos la pregunta es de
verdad estas empresas van a ser capaces
de encontrar nuevos clientes de un día
para otro pues lo más probable es que no
y eso significa miles de personas en el
paro personas que fácilmente podrían
encontrar un buen trabajo en cualquier
otro país conclusión antes de que les
cierran las fronteras se marchan y si
habéis oído bien antes de que cierran
las fronteras porque el riesgo de que
rusia no les deje salir es muy pero que
muy real de hecho en todos los foros de
internet están recomendando ahora mismo
borrar todos los mensajes de whatsapp y
de telegram antes de dejar el país y
diréis por qué pues porque la policía
rusa está haciendo auténticos
interrogatorios en el aeropuerto
cualquier mensaje de móvil que puede
interpretarse como anti ruso o anti
putin puede llevarles a la cárcel o
impedirles dejar el país y os
preguntaréis y hacia dónde están yendo
todos estos rusos pues ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver
[Música]
sálvese quien pueda
os voy a dar un ejemplo real aunque no
puedo dar nombres para respetar la
privacidad empresa rusa de informática
con 500 trabajadores tenía varios
clientes en japón en principio no los
han perdido ahora bien se tienen que
marchar de rúsia y entonces que han
hecho pues marcharse a dubai con todo el
equipo tal cual como lo oís dubai no ha
sancionado a rusia así que el ceo de la
empresa rusa ha montado una nueva
compañía en dubai y ha movido a toda su
plantilla pero esperad un momento porque
dubai no es el único lugar que está
recibiendo rusos por supuesto si eres un
millonario o un programador de altísimo
nivel dubai es desde luego un destino
muy atractivo pero tiene un problema es
muy caro y diréis qué pasa con el resto
de profesionales pues en la mayor parte
de los casos están siendo destinos mucho
menos atractivos pero más asequibles
países como kazajistán india o georgia
está recibiendo miles de trabajadores
rusos en cuestión de semanas y diréis
pero quién querría irse a vivir a
kazajistán ya lo sé nadie ha dicho nunca
mi sueño es vivir en almaty pero
pensadlo bien ahora mismo cualquier
lugar es mejor que la rusia de putin
[Música]
por ejemplo más de 25.000 personas se
han marchado ya georgia entre ellos está
uno de los youtubers rusos más conocidos
en occidente en el fk rz e incluso ya ha
subido su primer vídeo desde tíflis la
capital de georgia solo en el mes de
febrero 44 mil rusos cruzaron la
frontera con finlandia el mes anterior
esta cifra fue de menos de 27.000
[Música]
y aquí es donde llegamos al gran
problema que denunciamos en este vídeo
porque qué pasa con esos rusos que
llegan a finlandia es decir a la unión
europea pueden buscar un trabajo pueden
comprarse una casa pueden integrarse en
la economía europea pues la respuesta es
no habéis oído bien europa está
aceptando rusos como turistas es decir
con un visado que les permite quedarse
unos meses pero no buscar un trabajo al
menos no de forma legal y ya sé lo que
estaréis pensando sobre todo si sois
fans de visual política para vos qué
decisión más inteligente pero por favor
quién quiere que venga gente joven a
trabajar a europa quien necesita
personas que vengan aquí a pagar las
pensiones por favor entendéis lo que
quiero decir verdad
europa tiene dos problemas gigantescos
la crisis de las pensiones y la escasez
de mano de obra y si ya sé lo que
estaréis pensando sobre todo si veis
este vídeo desde países como españa
parece un insulto decir que hay escasez
de mano de obra pero lo cierto es que
hay sectores donde es casi imposible
encontrar trabajadores por ejemplo todo
lo que tenga que ver con ciberseguridad
las empresas europeas están desesperadas
por encontrar especialistas en
ciberseguridad y los estados europeos
están desesperados por encontrar gente
que pague pensiones así que todos esos
rusos que querrían venir a europa
suponen dos oportunidades una
descapitalizan a rusia porque les dejan
sin sus mejores profesionales dos nos
ayudan a pagar pensiones y a ser mucho
más competitivos la pregunta es por qué
europa los está rechazando pues ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
odia putin ama a los rusos
ya lo hemos contado en varios vídeos de
visual política todos los países tienen
programas de inmigración especiales para
atraer talento y dinero
independientemente de la visión que
tengáis cada uno sobre los inmigrantes
nadie al menos nadie con dos dedos de
frente pone en duda que es bueno atraer
talento y dinero y eso explica por
ejemplo la famosa visa h-1b uno de eeuu
por donde han entrado miles de personas
a silicon valley y si en este apartado
donde también podríamos meter todas esas
visas doradas con las que los oligarcas
rusos entraron en london grado o en
otros lugares como marbella en españa'
de repente han llegado a las sanciones
vale perfecto europa no quiere más
oligarcas rusos conectados a putin nada
que objetar a esto pero y qué pasa con
los profesionales qué pasa con ese
hacker ruso que tiene 30 años y que no
tiene ninguna conexión con putin ni con
su gobierno porque no se le iba a poder
contratar diréis pero de verdad hay
tantas empresas deseosas de contratar a
rusos y la respuesta es que sí
y
os voy a poner otro ejemplo real donde
no puedo citar nombres por privacidad
multinacional del sector alimentación
con sedes por todo el mundo vamos a
llamar esta empresa a cme por ponerle un
nombre ficticio acaban de cerrar sus
oficinas en moscú debido a las sanciones
sin embargo desde su sede en barcelona
acne españa quiere contratar a buena
parte de la plantilla de acné rusia son
perfiles muy útiles que obviamente no
quieren perder y aquí es donde llega el
problema porque los empleados de acme
rusia llegan al consulado de españa en
moscú y les dicen pues es que los
sentimos no podemos procesar vuestro
visado no podemos demostrar vuestra
experiencia profesional y diréis por qué
pues porque aquí me rusia ya no existe
desapareció antes de ayer dicho de otra
forma en el currículum de toda esta
gente figura que han trabajado en una
empresa fantasma y esto hace legalmente
imposible procesar su visado porque pues
atentos
[Música]
la principal forma para entrar
legalmente en españa desde fuera de la
unión europea es con la llamada ley de
inversiones aprobada en 2014 casi todos
los países europeos tienen leyes
parecidas a esto es a lo que nos
referimos normalmente como las visas
doradas esta ley permite conseguir un
visado de dos formas distintas
invirtiendo una gran suma de dinero en
españa' o bien siendo lo que se llama un
alto profesional
y diréis pero como define la ley lo que
es un alto profesional pues muy sencillo
se trata de un profesional con un perfil
tan especializado que es casi imposible
sustituirlo por una persona local para
eso es necesario presentar títulos
universitarios y experiencia profesional
el problema por un lado las
universidades rusas no están homologadas
con las europeas y la experiencia
profesional de un ruso es indemostrable
en este momento es tan sencillo como eso
los consulados europeos no están
aceptando los currículums de miles de
profesionales rusos y esto tiene tres
derivadas muy pero que muy preocupantes
la primera es que manda el mensaje
equivocado a los rusos les está diciendo
putin tiene toda la razón occidente odia
a todos y cada uno de los rusos así que
la rusofobia existe cerremos filas con
el gobierno y la segunda es que europa
está perdiendo una oportunidad muy buena
para atraer talento y contribuyentes y
la tercera es que europa no está
generando el 'efecto llamada' que
necesitaría porque entenderéis que no es
lo mismo dejar rusia sabiendo que tus
únicas alternativas son cada cristal o
la india que dejar rusia sabiendo que te
espera una vida mucho mejor en la unión
europea dicho de otra forma que si ves
este vídeo desde un consulado en rusia
ponte las pilas porque el tiempo apremia
y bien digo el tiempo apremia la ventana
de oportunidad es única es cuestión de
tiempo que rusia cierra sus fronteras es
decir que al kremlin no le quede más
remedio que prohibir a todos sus
ciudadanos abandonar el país
[Música]
no sería la primera vez que ocurre desde
el año 1922 la antigua unión soviética
cerró sus puertas a todos sus ciudadanos
en 1961 la república democrática de
alemania es decir alemania del este
llegó a construir un muro en berlín para
evitar que nadie pudiera cruzar la
frontera a berlín occidental y todo esto
se debe a una razón rusia no puede
permitirse perder más talento así que
ahora la pregunta es para vosotros si os
ocurre alguna razón por la que europa no
debería aceptar a los trabajadores rusos
de verdad europa llegar a abrir sus
puertas al talento ruso que se está
marchando ahora mismo qué consecuencias
puede tener esto en la guerra de ucrania
podéis dejar me vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
que aquí en visual político sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribir a este canal y dadle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones por supuesto no
olvidéis también visitar nuestro patria
si os ha gustado este vídeo dadle a like
y nos vemos en el próximo un abrazo y
hasta pronto
[Música]